no protectors here
this world will fall like all the others
i had a dream it was the end of the
world
he said the age of heroes would never
come again it has to
oh awesome
don't engage alone we'll do this
together
each of us in some way is held back
this is crazy
this why i brought you together mostly i
think we're all gonna die
superman was a beacon to the world
he made them see the best parts of themselves
Fighting the devil and his army in hell
my turn
shall we
we're doing it so get ready
this guy's probably fought hundreds of
thousands of other super beings on the
other planets he's destroyed right and
we have to assume he's won i don't care
how many demons he's fought and how many
hells
he's never fought us not us united
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my justice league snyder
cut trailer video they revealed a whole
bunch of details
that weren't in the actual trailer
footage so i'll explain that during the
video too
bunch of easter eggs here whole bunch of
new scenes so if you're new to the
channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
other trailer videos there was so much
stuff this weekend suicide squad trailer
wonder woman 1984 trailer
i'll try to do videos for everything i'm
also giving away this dc fandom box of
merch that they sent me all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and just
let me know what your favorite
trailer from the weekend was so i'll
just start with the footage first then
i'll explain
what's going to happen how they're going to
release it and all the other details
that zack snyder revealed about the
movie
but the entire cast of the justice
league was on the panel reading
questions from the fans and talking
about the snyder cut
but it opens up with a scene of darkseid
in that big flashback dark side war
scene where he's fighting the combined
armies of the amazons the atlanteans the
humans the green lanterns
notice that zack snyder was hyping this
up earlier this year like everyone was
excited to see darkseid come back to the
movie because in the theatrical cut this
was steppenwolf in the flashbacks
he's wielding a giant spear that you can
see wonder woman looking at later in the
trailer closer to present day
but notice the center of his chest it
seems like he's got this deep impression
sunken in just waiting for the omega
symbol to show up
during the events of this flashback it's
thousands of years ago in our history
he hasn't received the omega force yet
so he doesn't have his full powers
that's why he's fighting with a weapon
in why he loses to them and why you
don't see him using the omega beams
because if he had those he'd be able
to trash all those armies all by himself
single-handedly
the music track playing on this you'll
probably recognize it's leonard cone's
hallelujah
it's actually on zack snyder's watchmen
because he uses a lot of leonard cohen
tracks on his movies
there was one playing at the beginning
of the theatrical cut i don't know if
zack snyder was responsible of putting
that there or if it was joss whedon that
chose to put that song on there
usually it's zack snyder that puts the
leonard cohen songs on his movies
i put a different song under the trailer
at the beginning of this just to keep it
copyright safe
just because music is going to get
claimed right away i couldn't put that
leonard cohen track in my video
but then they have a flashback scene to
superman dying during the events of
batman v
superman this will make sense in a
second too because there's some scenes
that seem like they take place during
batman v
superman but it's all new footage in the
justice league movie
there's a much longer version of the
batman nightmare scene
notice the rubble you see the ruins the
hall of justice that's the old wayne
manor batman was going to build that at the
end of the justice league theatrical cut
like look we could put chairs in here
room for more
the nightmare scene is supposed to take
place a couple years into the future in
this post-apocalyptic environment after
darkseid has come back conquered earth
and enslaved superman using the
anti-life equation that was why all the
parademons had the superman symbol on
their armor
but if you look amongst the rubble of
wayne manor here the old hall of justice
you notice some easter eggs you see a
picture of the justice league you see
aquaman's trident implying the dark side
killed him or he had
superman kill him for him there's a
joker playing card that blows by
implying that he was killed too
probably a lot of other heroes and
villains they had a bunch more of dark
side ships to the skyline we didn't see
any of that during those batman v
superman versions of the scene
then you see a different scene of wonder
woman walking through ruins maybe the
greek temple to get info on darkseid she
sees the spear that he left behind when
they defeated him in the past thousands
of years ago
it seems like this scene takes place
right before the other scene they
released earlier where you see her
looking at the painting of darkseid and
then they flash back to him getting
ready to fight everyone
there are a bunch of other scenes of the
dark side war flashback scenes as well
you see the atlanteans you see king
atlan
or their version of king atlan fighting
them they changed the actor for the
aquaman movie but that's who this is
supposed to be
you get a longer version of that trailer
scene where batman is looking at footage
of superman this is
probably before he's been resurrected
earlier in the movie
you get a much longer version of the
aquaman introduction scene of him saving
the dude he carries into the bar
there's a big cyborg flashback scene of
him before he was fused with the mother
box and got his powers at the football
game
then there's a scene of superman coming
back in the kryptonian ship his fortress
of solitude in the black suit right
after
this deleted scene getting ready to join
the justice league in the big final
battle against steppenwolf
noticed the black suit so just
confirming that he will have the black
suit for most of the movie
this person actually seems like he's
meant to be da'sod or one of darkseid's
other disciples
there's a much longer version of that
wonder woman introduction scene from
early in the movie when she's saving
that tour group at the museum
there's a big deleted scene of the flash
using his abilities to save iris west
from the car accident this is the
keirsey clemens version of iris west
i don't know if she's coming back for
the flash movie or if they've recaster
they haven't really explained that yet
there was a panel for the flash movie
they revealed a whole bunch of really
cool concept art of keaton's batman
and they showed off the new flash
costume ben affleck's batman is actually
going to make the flash's new costume
for him during the movie as well
i'll do a separate video for the flash
movie teaser that they released so don't
worry that'll post in the next couple of
days
zack snyder also teased that the flash
would show off some quote unquote new
quantum
abilities during the movie that we've
never seen before or at least during the
snyder cut version of the movie
i think what he was talking about were
these scenes here in the big final
battle
with a flash actually time travels just
to set up the flash movie plot of him
going back doing flashpoint
like this does not look like normal
flash running through the speed force it
seems like he's running back through
time
and you also see the separate scene of
him seemingly jumping around
all over the place but it doesn't look
like he's using the speed force
this is just a scene of cyborg digging
up superman's body slightly different
version that we saw during the
theatrical
cut this is a longer version of lois
lane talking to martha kent after
superman has died
there's a much bigger version of aquaman
coming to get his armor and his mother's
trident but the way they cut it makes it
seem like he's actually leaving them
behind
this might just be misleading the way
that they've cut this scene this scene
of cyborg's father in star labs is him
trying to use the mother box and it just
ending
horribly being vaporized by the energy
the ryan choi
version of the atom is also a character
in the snyder cut but i don't think that
he's going to be
doing any actual adam comic book stuff i
think he's just playing ryan choi and
it's implied that he might eventually
become the atom at some point
there's a whole new version of the scene
of steppenwolf at the beginning of the
movie coming through the boom two to get
the amazon's mother box just completely
redone
special effects this is the character
model for zack snyder's version of
steppenwolf
looks very different way more hardcore
there's a very different version of the
superman versus steppenwolf scene at the
end of the movie with him in his black
suit just giving him the business all
over the place then there's a scene of
superman from earlier in the movie
coming back to the ken farm with martha
ken and lois lane
cyborg seeming like he's using his
abilities to attack steppenwolf or
superman or someone else just using a
whole bunch of missiles to attack
something
then there's the scene of cyborg trying
to save the cop from the flying tank
this actually seems like it's coming
from the scene where they're fighting
superman and this is just collateral
damage with stuff flying all over the
place
then there's a very different version of
that ending scene of them all standing
together
after defeating steppenwolf getting
ready to board batman ship and go home
then a tag scene of them talking about
how they're actually going to fight
steppenwolf and darkseid
he's fought thousands of other super
beings on other planets and beaten them
thinking about green lanterns
kryptonians other space-based races in
the dc comics universe
and you get batman's rally cry i don't
care how many demons he's fought and how
many hells he's never fought us together
united aka the justice league so the
really important stuff this is coming
next
spring sometime i believe they didn't
list an exact release date they probably
haven't quite decided yet
probably sometime april may but they're
going to air it as a mini series in four
parts each part will be one hour long
and they'll air the episodes weekly
so four hour snyder cut but they will
bundle it together and release a four
hour cut sometime later there might be a
home video version
and they're working on international
distribution plans so if you don't have
hbo max
available in your country they will have
some way for you to legally
actually watch the snyder cut when it
comes of course i'll do videos for
all the episodes and easter eggs it'll
be crazy there'll be a whole bunch of
new stuff it'll be really fun to talk
about
there were so many other big dc movie
trailers this weekend like the batman
trailer the suicide squad trailer the
black adam teaser the flash movie teaser
i've got videos for all those that i'm
going to be posting in the next couple
of days if i haven't already so as long
as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see those videos when
i post them but everyone just let me
know in the comments what you're most
hyped up about where your favorite
trailer from the weekend was
everyone click here to watch the batman
trailer with robert pattinson a billion
more times
and click here for all my other dc
fandom movie trailers
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!